Банківські рахунки під арештом.
Все, що сплачують пасажири за проїзд, іде фактично
на погашення боргу Київського метрополітену
за 75 російських вагонів і 25 українських,
які придбали ще в2009році,  кажуть експерти.
Цей лізинговий контракт метрополітен, за згоди Київради,
уклав з російською компанією Укррослізинг.
Після Майдану в2014-ому
Київрада припинила виплати, мовляв, Київ
не буде платити компанії з країни-агресора.
Втім Укррослізинг не був внесений РНБО
до санкційного списку. І за чотири роки борг зріс
до майже двох мільярдів гривень.
Саме цю суму має сплатити Київський метрополітен,
програвши суд Укррослізингу.
Суди визнали цей контракт чиним
і визнали всю суму боргу.
Те,що нам вдалося відстояти:
компанія першочергово планувала забрати і вагони,
і стягнути борг.
Те, що нам вдалося відстояти,
що всі вагони залишилися у власності метрополітену.
Замість одного мільярда трьохсот мільйонів гривень -
це сума контракту, Києву доведеться тепер сплатити
фактично дві ціни. Або, якщо уважно роздивитися
умови контракту і його учасників,
то, за підрахунками експертів Центру протидії корупції,
Київ сплатить чотири ціни за вагони.
Всі ці підприємстства - прокладки.
Юрист Центру протидії корупції відтворює схему,
як російські вагони в Україну були завезені
з Литви через британську фірму, яка має відношення
до екс-нардепа від Партії регіонів Юрія Іванющенка,
а потім перекинуті ще через дві фірми в Донецьку і Києві.
Зухвалість схеми, на думку Андрія Савіна,
нічим не поступається так званим "вишкам Бойка".
Згідно з аудиторським висновком, ще який був складений
в2013-му році
під час Майдану, складає 700 мільйонів гривень переплата.
Тобто, майже вдвічі дорожче. Тобто, ці вагони
малиб коштувати 600 мільйонів гривень.
В контексті лізингового контракту було відкрито
кілька кримінальних проваджень. Але фактично єдиним,
хто наразі постане перед судом, буде один з екс-заступників
начальника Київського метрополітену.
На думку юриста, через бездіяльність Генпрокуратури
шанс взагалі скасувати рішення Київради
від2009-го року щодо укладання цього контракту - втрачено.
Вони б мали встановити всю цю схему,
розслідувати не зловживання з боку службових осіб метрополітену,
а встановлювати заздалегідьсплановану корупційну схему,
яка має ознаки розкраданнякоштів міста Києва.
Оплачувати лізинговий контракт і виконувати
судове рішення про погашення боргу
має Київрада з бюджету міста.
Наразі депутати дали згоду лише на те, аби метрополітен
почав перемовини щодо реструктуризації боргу.
Поки що не ідеться про виділення коштів,
про те звідки буде це фінансування.
Ідеться про те, щоб вийти на контакт з компанією,
обговорити в принципіможливість погашення цього боргу.
Поки тривали всі судові засідання, Укррослізинг
став українським підприємством.
За цей час в метро двічі підвищували вартість проїзду,
але заперечували зв'язок з необхідністю погашення боргу.
Лізинговий контракт прив’язаний до курсу долара,
і борг у разі несвоєчасного погашення буде лише зростати.